we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p call anytime here's a voicemail
i received the avec [ __ ] joy York from
allendale Alabama uh we're talking about
oxford alabama and i didn't like the way
you said uh alabama like three or four
times in a very kind ascending and
practical way and uh maybe instead worry
about furred Alabama you should be
worried about that one town in
Massachusetts all those thousand
Massachusetts all right we'll listen all
worried about Massachusetts I do like
you could never get laid because they're
all lesbians I think he's probably
talking about Northampton Massachusetts
where the show originated considered a
sort of uh top lesbian uh destination of
the country uh yeah listen list is
plenty heterosexual women in Northampton
I don't live in northampton i live in
boston uh III said the name of alabama
I'm sorry if if you have so much of a
self-conscious nature about Alabama that
merely mentioning the state makes you
feel bad but I don't know that I did
anything wrong there we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today I don't even
have time to tell you what stories are
on it but you can sign up on our website
david pakman.com plenty more stories
later on on the bonus show